okay so i'm getting ready she went red
bull red for that
okay guys so the topic of today is it's
2022 y'all
do we need feminism in 2022
yes or no go around yeah yes yes i think
so yes definitely yes
no
i'm in between i'm in between you're in
between yeah okay so um my stance is i i
don't see anything holding women back in
2022 and i don't know what we need
feminism for today so i'd be curious
from the girls that said yes like what
you think we need feminism for
the pay gap
okay the pay gap yeah um but the pay gap
is not real it still is no it's not it
is
um no every the thing is like when you
take into
account things like like personality
differences the pay gap doesn't exist
like like um for example google did a
study
on like they thought they were paying
women less than men
and they found out they were paying then
eight percent left when they take into
account things like hours worked and
their time time their experience
like there's no there's no pay gap
okay fair enough i don't have statistics
that i will
yeah pass
well
i don't have the statistics to back it
up but um okay i believe it when you say
it yeah okay
it's okay um i i think it's like common
to be honest like a lot of people
like that it's kind of pushed in the
media and stuff but any like economist
that's worth a damn will tell you the
pickup doesn't exist
like women
women aren't in 20 like we make 70 to 80
of consumer buying decisions the entire
media is marketed to women
so i don't know what i'm just curious
like what are we fighting for in 2022 i
mean when it comes to the pay gap it's
like um
it's like this if you advertise a job
on the internet
and say this job is
x and this is a salary
it's not oh this is a salary for women
and this is salary for men right it says
this is the salary so
every person that applies for that job
whether you be male or female is going
to get that salary and one of the major
reasons went for the pay gap is that we
talked about uh men being more
disagreeable and women be more agreeable
so in a job
men are more likely
to fight for a pay rise than a woman is
did you know sixty percent of women have
never asked for a pay rise yeah sixty 60
so what happens is that men get into
these positions okay it was i don't know
70 000 a year
and it's like they start doing their
work and they're like hang on a minute
i'm doing all of these hours i'm doing
all of this work as a matter of fact i
think i deserve a raise and they go to
the boss and say look
i deserve a raise and so men are
more uh
let's just say forthright with asking
for pay rises so a lot of the time
within the pay gap is because men have
actually taken the time out to say you
know what i want more women are like
yeah you know what i'm not really going
to go and ask the boss for more money
and stuff and
yeah all right i'm fine with the job
it's a good job men are like no i'm
doing all these hours and generally men
work more hours than women
they just generally do so a lot of the
time the pay gap is because men work
more hours than women do
men work
harder jobs than women do
men work in more so in the stem fields
as
science technology engineering
mathematics not to say women can't go
into those stem fields
we have the same equal opportunities
that you do you can go into science
technology engineering mathematics those
are very high paying jobs but women
choose generally not to go into those
fields they choose to go into other
fields so that's one of the reasons for
the pay gap but there's women on those
fields yeah there are and they get paid
the same as men but in those fields men
choose to yeah get more aggressive and
say listen i deserve more
yeah but probably some women are afraid
to actually ask for more because
probably the boss is a male and he will
say no and most of the times they say no
because you are a woman and they see us
less in a way and actually we are living
in a men's society and let's be honest
still
we need feminism you know but we're not
living in a moment why'd you say we live
in demand society sorry like how are we
living in a man's society of 70 to 80
percent because women are afraid still
to ask for a raise
why are you afraid i'm not i'm not i'm
always asking for more every year so
yeah and i i get it but why but so why
women why are women afraid then i i
don't know because they probably they've
been in that place and they've been
rejected you know or probably they never
like you said before as well they don't
have the same uh
you know god's feeling as men like going
forward and ask for more but we
we know as women
i i that's my uh that's my i say that's
how i think and that's how i feel and
that's how i see women back back but
ages ago
but that doesn't mean you're right like
i'm a girl i've always i don't want it
but i'm sorry i'm saying
i'm saying
i'm saying i've always been in male
dominated fields i've never had anything
it's been easier for me because like i'm
young and like like men
i feel like men are more inclined to
help girls they're attracted to like
just being 100 yeah and it's like i feel
like i've gotten more opportunity being
a girl and you stand out more
like like i was in sales i sold copiers
and like i never had an issue i always
got help from men i never had a problem
asking for more money but then men shame
us
i actually
saw one time a man saying oh why men why
women wear makeup while they are going
to their you know workplace because they
are trying to seduce they are trying you
know to get their way
to get what they want probably you know
so you see we are ashamed by men as well
but the the reason is because we use our
looks we are shamed by men if we don't
do it
by men you know it's just like do you
think we have always something to you
know to get judged by men do you and
that's why yeah you know
women are afraid to ask
if you're if but if you're afraid then
that's on you no i'm just saying not me
i'm saying women in general if they're
afraid that's on them and the thing is
we as a man i understand like men
men deal with men a certain way and men
understand like male energy so if a man
goes to a man he understands okay cool
another man's coming to me
cool we have to you know deal with this
male energy
if women are afraid to deal with men in
this in this society then i think that's
a that's a woman problem isn't it
because we can have a conversation like
i know every person has male and female
energy as a man and as a woman we both
have those energies and i think of
course a woman has to learn
uh how to deal with that energy and use
for her benefit as a as a man as well
you know has to be understanding and
more
like to listen more women
than rather like judging you know so
when it comes like a woman to actually
ask for like to read to raise their i'm
sorry my english is a bit i stumble but
anyway
if he if the woman asks more she's
always seen as a gold eager or
um i don't think you are worth as a man
doing that the same job i think he does
better you know wait who is that is that
factual is that something that you just
feel yeah because who does that like
that's never like that's never happened
to me but that's you right but it's just
one or two in that you
you know it happens it it can happen in
that way too but it can happen the other
side as well you know this world is
quite big there's a lot of people i
don't believe there is like equality
when it comes to be paid everywhere
well
i don't believe it the statistics will
you can also wrong
you can make me like i said like donald
trump you know there's a lot of
statistics about a lot of it and when we
see like real life like real cases
close people
then so are you saying you'd believe
what you believe regardless of any data
and statistics put in front of you like
it does it doesn't matter any any data
it's just like what you
believe
um
i like i like to see real cases like i i
heard a lot about statistics and then
you just hear like stories about real
people well i'm a real person
but i'm a real person i know but like so
so the statistics then i'm just saying
right people who are not they exist as
well you know so we cannot generalize
all of it
sure sure but i'm saying like it's just
interesting that it doesn't like because
to me if you gave me counter evidence or
counter data that like
showed that the pay gap was real
then sure i would look at it and maybe
change my opinion but i've just i've
researched this a lot because of the
channel
and like i'm telling you there's study
after study after study after study
saying that
the the pay gap
if there is one it's as close as three
percent
and some studies say that women are paid
more than men
so
so it's just like how can i look at all
this evidence and not
have a different opinion you know what i
mean and i understand it's not in front
of you maybe you don't take my word for
it that's fine like you don't you don't
have to believe me but that's what i'm
asking like if you had these studies in
front of you would would that change
your opinion or would you just keep
i'm not doubting what are you saying i'm
just saying i believe there's still
cases out there women are not being paid
like you know as men like the same
that's what i'm saying okay yeah yeah
all
right
no i was gonna say like i understand
where you're coming from because
i
i thought that as well
after seeing a video of
jordan jordan
jordan peterson just wanted to get his
name right he was talking about it and
he's he's not just some joe smo off the
street but he was talking he's a
psychologist very well known professor
and everything he's very good video he
was talking about how
the reason why there is
or
if there is a pay gap is not based on
someone being a man or a woman but
there's
traits that because you were saying
if men and women have those male uh
those masculine and feminine traits and
if
a woman would
essentially tap into those
male traits
they would be able to walk up to whoever
it is and be like i deserve to be paid
more because that's a trait that
masculinity has there
it's that like dog in them to be able to
be like no i deserve this but we as
women we
is it empathy or it's agreeable we're
more agreeable we're more agreeable and
it's just who we are so it's a little
bit more difficult for us to be able to
step out not saying that there's not
cases where
women do get paid less than men but
they're also on the flip side where in
certain industry
men do get paid less than women
so like when you take modeling for
example
like women get paid more than men in
that industry yeah supermodels yeah
female super models get paid more than
male 1
would you would would you like equality
in the super model world like the men
get paid as much as the women
yeah makes sense i mean about modeling
let's see like for example kendall
jenner she's like one of the most
i think it's the first
billionaire yeah yeah i mean but she
even comparing to other women as well
yeah but i'm saying like if you look at
history when it comes to modeling right
like
supermodels
being women have been paid
far much more than men
like but men aren't saying oh my god we
need equality within the modeling
industry we need to be paid because
there are male models out there and they
do you know they have campaigns and what
but they don't get paid as much as the
women do so they didn't speak out for
that
right exactly so but they could speak
out they they could exactly they didn't
it's their choice but i'm saying
so do you think that male models should
be paid as much as female models yeah
why not if you guys do the same job why
not what's the difference here
for me it's about equality it's not i
don't see a man or
a woman more or less i see as we both
are the same level you know we are
humans we are people it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter the gender you know
for me you are a person like me you are
a human you are the same as me we are
the same [ __ ] i'm just saying of course
we are different in gender but when it
comes to rights i think we all deserve
the same so then why so then okay so
let's put that into the real world so
then why would uh why is a woman more
likely to get into a club for free than
a man is
well i didn't do the rule i didn't do
the rules do you know what i'm saying
equality
you know why because they want more
women in the club than men so they
attract men to pay the bill right so
these men are the hungry ones to get
more money so that makes sense you guys
did the math so that double stance
right so that double standard there that
double standard
was created by men right but it but
you're okay with that though oh yeah
because we get in for free right okay so
that's right
that's important that's it
that's the that's the point so you're
okay with double standards when it when
it when it benefits you
you're not okay with double standards
when it doesn't benefit us
if you are getting paid more doesn't it
even if we don't get paid more or the
same as you guys it doesn't like we
don't take your benefits do we no yes
you in some cases yes when you implement
things like quotas i'll give you an
example i worked in the copier industry
they needed women because selling
copiers honestly is a [ __ ] job i don't
know a lot of girls that want to do it i
shouldn't do it right right
i shouldn't have done it but then they
hired any girl that walked through the
door whether or not it was she was
qualified or not because they needed
women they needed to fill their quotas
and like then you have unqualified women
in jobs they don't deserve
and so and then that hurts men because
you're taking away opportunities from
people that actually are qualified and
deserve them
but the person who to blame here is not
the women who are hired is the person
who hires the people
no the the person to blame is the person
that implemented a quota um because
that's not no no we we women we came
here to get you know our rights uh-huh
but not to say oh i deserve a job even
though i'm not qualified i'm not coming
from there but essentially that's what
in my eyes that's what feminism is it's
just like it doesn't matter
what it is
it should be a right for a woman so no
matter if you're qualified or not you
should be able to
get the job
i don't know because that's true i don't
agree with that then
i don't i don't i don't see you in that
way
yeah that's earlier you're asking for
like equality when you're like man women
should be paid the same it should be
equal but the question is like equal at
what cost
so so if you if you just pay people the
same if like you say a man and a woman
they're equal but what if one does a
better job than the other
and if you take into account like if you
look at the studies men work longer
hours than women
because you decide to stay long yeah and
so so if you work longer hours you
should get paid more yeah but then is
good so then the page
right so then
you can't complain about the pay gap
no exactly you're right i i'm with you
but i'm saying like so then when men
start making more money we cannot
complain you can't complain we work more
hours let me just clarify when i said
page up i don't mean people that work
that men that work extra hours i meant
people that do the exact same job that
have the exact same qualifications
getting paid exactly that's exactly
right
people are not qualified that's that's
your problem no but then so then like
that's that's what it seems like on the
outside but you can't look at it at face
value
because you have to look as to why is
there that gap and so another aspect is
personality differences like what jess
was saying earlier
so 60 of women haven't asked for a raise
ever and they'll quit their job before
they ask for a raise
so is that is that men's fault that we
chose not to ask for a raise
because i i have a friend who
works in
can't exactly remember she works in but
she makes a good amount of money and
when she got a new position
she was like should i ask for a raise
and i was like yes ask for it and when
she asked for a certain amount of money
that was
uh similar to her counterparts which
were males she got it and i think it's
just something that has been
subconsciously talked to us like don't
ask for raise that's going to be rude if
you ask for more money that they've
already
given you when it's not rude if you
think you are worth a certain amount of
money and you are qualified for a
position to go and ask it's something
that we've been
just taught as women it's like don't do
something because
it may ruffle somebody's feather we have
to be peacemakers we can't upset anybody
we have to be calm a situation and i
think that's one reason why we don't do
certain things as women because we don't
want to upset anybody or
make anybody feel like we're ungrateful
for something that they've already
given us when we shouldn't have to feel
like that if we think that we're worth
something because in a relationship if
you feel like you're worth more in a
relationship you're going to get out of
that relationship no matter how long it
may take you you're going to be like i'm
worth more in this relationship i'm
going to step out of it but when it
comes down to money it's like
we're essentially silencing ourself
because we don't ask for more plus it's
illegal
it's illegal to say i'm going to pay you
less because you're a woman
it's illegal you can't that's there's no
law that says yeah pay a woman less so
men and women have to be paid the same
for the same job when they pick more
like dangerous jobs like men are men are
23 times more likely to die in the
workplace than women
yeah so they're going to be paid more if
they pick more dangerous jobs
i think when you put it in that
perspective i guess i like i would agree
with just like i'm in between because
um like back then so what the feminist
movement started around what 1848 when
they first did it i think that's what
yeah 1848 started in new york so like
obviously women were fighting for
something different and um women's
rights or like voting for like just to
vote was like 1920 was in 1920 when the
women first got to vote i think
yeah
so
back then women were fighting for so
much more and like we're getting
that now so that makes sense when you
guys are explaining it and the
statistics and things like that so just
giving me
a different perspective
on that rather than just
you know just saying we still need
like well i i i would i would ask a
question what rights does a woman have
today
that
men don't have
or what rights do men have today that
women don't
well
in culture in some cultures we don't
still have the same rights for example
in saudi arabia
right feminism probably would work would
would need to go there but we're not in
saudi arabia
sorry
we're talking about the western world
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i should have
clarified i just met in like the uk us
like
in the western world
because i went to saudi arabia so i was
speaking now right very bright right
yeah but the women in saudi arabia will
say
we're fine no they're not i've been
there for two months
so i i spoke with you
you may think that they're fine i'm not
saying that
they're not but
there's they may think in their
situation like oh we're fine here
because they've been in it so long and
you're an outsider looking in and you
have a different view of how a woman's
life should be and you're like you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that that
shouldn't be your life and
they may think like oh this is what
we've done for so long and i don't know
if you've had people like come to you
and say like you know okay
like for example i was a a monkey there
in saudi arabia was a clothing shop
and she was working at the at the teal
and
she was sharing basically she asked me
oh where are you from you know and i'm
like i'm from portugal but i live in
london and she's like oh my god i'd love
to go to london and but i never traveled
i'm 28. uh i need permission to go like
outside of the country with my like i
need to ask my father to go in order to
visit any other country but he never
like allowed me to go
so i'm just like you know
i i don't think i would ever get out of
the country
so she said she has actually to marry
someone
and then probably probably yes or no
uh the husband
would think it would take a second
maybe yeah
you know she cannot even go travel by
herself
which is really really
disgusting and then you have to cover
yourself and i saw all these men like in
high temperatures i was sweating like a
pig you know i i had a high job i had to
cover my shoulder i had to cover
everything and
you see you would see men like shards
and shirts and us all covered you know
and there's women have menopause women
have hormones
okay men too but women have menstruation
women get pregnant women you know we all
go through all pain through our lives
since we are born we as women you know
and
we have to cover ourselves there with 39
degrees
honestly
i feel for the women of course i feel
for every woman because i have to be
that woman but you know okay but we're
talking so we're talking about the uk in
the us
so in in the uk like i'm just curious
because i can't think of a single thing
in the uk and the us we're really
fighting for that we can't do
um
yeah so now yes because we are very like
yeah yeah and the question is like has
it has feminism really helped us are
women happier today
uh
i think so
are women happier today
are you i am
i'm very independent i'm very happy i
get always more i ask for more i always
get more
so
does independence lead to happiness yes
oh yes when i'm with a man actually
it kind of stops me so so like so if you
were 60 it's childless and by yourself
if you were 65 let's say childless by
yourself no family you'd be like you
think you'd be happy yeah with a dog
ooh
she said
kevin samuel says buy a dog and die
alone i would have two dogs so the dog
has someone to play with when i'm not at
home so i'm not that selfish you know
but yeah i'll be very happy a nice house
in front of the beach two dogs there i
would have men by like desertino how do
you know
28.
see if you're if you think that at 38.
so maybe i'm dead let's see
no i don't wish death on yourself no i'm
not me neither but you never know yeah
but i'm saying like because now i think
like
women that are in their younger years
think yeah i'm
because i'm happy now
right and i
and i'm single now and i'm independent
now
i'm gonna be i'm gonna have this mindset
into my 50s and 60s about when you get
to like your 40s 50s and 60s you tend to
want some kind of companionship you tend
to want somebody who you'd like to like
be with on a day to day or on a
week-to-week basis someone to hold
someone to go to sleep with but you know
it at that point in time a lot of women
tend to
think that they're going to have the
same mindset like i'm 41
right but
yeah i know i look good right yeah black
don't
a lot of people think that they have the
same i never had the same mindset that i
have now than when i did when i was 25.
i mean 28. do you know i mean and at
that age i thought i knew it all i
thought yeah i know exactly what i want
yeah i'm gonna be like this rest of my
life i'm telling you
time changes your mind and you may think
that now but as you get to 38 and you
have to be like yeah i'm going to buy a
dog i'm going to be like by myself by
the beach i'm telling you you're going
to want a companion over 42 that are
single childless and make between 50 and
100 000 are the least happy and the most
medicated
there you go um
i saw some messages like from elderly
care you know hillary clinton calorie
people and
most of women they say don't date
you know they're old
they're smiling yeah face but i've been
in a relationship before for seven years
and i was very happy and i just broke up
because i moved from switzerland to
london you know i know but it is a
relationship i know what it is to be
with someone you don't want that again
oh yes but not now
i just feel
um i had a man it's hot girl summer
season now
and not because
it's hot girl summer season
but it's not because of that it's
because
i feel
a man right now would
uh
delay me in a way because what i want in
life
it i just need to be focused i just need
to think about me just me i cannot share
so much time with a person if that makes
sense i hate you yeah so i don't want to
be selfish i don't want to be narcissist
in a way like he's giving me so much and
then i just cannot give the same so i'm
just very aware of that so i just feel
like probably i would have like
how you say how you call a hook up
there
and there here and there yeah and there
not really and that works for you in the
machine no i don't think so that's the
thing i don't think so it doesn't work i
want to try because i never i never
tried that's the thing i'm curious no oh
because i've been always a kind of girl
like so you relationship you essentially
want to be for the streets
kind of because i don't know the streets
so
she's curious about these streets okay
that's another lie that like like
feminism teaches to women that sleeping
around is gonna make you happy
and it's not you know your your chance
of a happy marriage if you if you're a
virgin when you get married
your chance of being happily married is
eighty percent all right yeah and it
drops down to thirty percent if you've
slept with more than five people
well what come again
it drops down
if you've slept with more than five
people
and it just keeps getting lower and
lower
the more guys you sleep with it gets
lower and lower because you know why you
know better what you know what you want
in bed you know sex is it it is
important it's messy right and it's not
just sex people think it's just sex or
[ __ ] it's not it's about intimacy you
know and it's about what you like and
what do you for
for
which person for the male or
uh female because i'm just a female i
just thought as a guy i would tell you a
guy can have sex with a hole in the wall
and be cool
what i'm telling you a guy
a guy can have sex with a woman i was
exaggerating there but a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy
that's not true
i'm a man i'm telling you a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy ah you don't need it of course
not but i'm just saying it is important
and once you have it believe me it's
much better than sex i don't disagree
with you but i'm saying guys can go
through their life having and that's the
reason why um only fans and porn it in
my opinion why only fans and porn is so
popular because guys can just jerk off
and be cool yeah but women that does
like we watch part two yeah but the
industry is it's a male-led industry
it's like the the most consumers of like
porn and only fans are male 1 they're
not females most women are sexually
active we're men that's not the case one
or three men under 30 are either virgins
or haven't had sex in a year
and that is why only fans and porn is so
um popular because these men these
averages these men are just in their
houses just jacking off and not having
sex ah
you know
they're just jacking off my ideas
they're not having sex that makes sense
because as a as women
scientifically we
release more
i forgot i think ever at the what we
release when we have sex that makes us
want that intimacy with whoever we're
having sex with we there are some women
who can just be like i'm just have sex
with him and not care but there's
something like in the back of your mind
that you still care about that person
because if you saw if you had sex with
that dude one day the next day he goes
and has sex with another female you're
going to feel some type of way because
of what we release
when we have sexual interaction with
them and it's just something that
we cannot
bypass because it's in us so
it's
it's hard to
be able to um
to
sleep around and i mean i'm speaking for
me it's hard to be able to sleep around
with multiple people and not have that
like oh i wonder if he's like thinking
about me or whatever
like because it's just like it's just
what
what like we release when we do interact
with them like that yeah and men can
have sex with like
like i always i've said this so many
times on the show but it's like the day
you realize you have to worry about the
ugly girls too
because like men can have
like men can have sex with literally
anyone anyone anyone
and be okay yeah like so as i said men
can have sex with a woman today and
another woman tomorrow and at three
women today and
be okay and it's not like oh like you
just said it's like he's not thinking oh
i wonder if they're thinking about me
just like no i just yeah
i just done that
it's totally different mindset imagine
if a guy gives you the best sex to your
life like mine
she says been there done that
but then then he never talks to you
again oh he did after seven years still
text me
imagine
no but she's saying imagine if a guy did
yeah and i'm saying like he did not
women have a harder time with that and
then it sort of ruins you a little bit
for your husband because now you compare
to him like your future husband to that
guy
and that's not really it's not really
fair like guys guys aren't really like
that they they have sex they're good but
like girls will compare
the next guy to the last guy so then
these guys feel like they have to like
be these
corn stars to like please a girl you
know what i mean and like they feel like
they have these unrealistic standards
and then and then a longer way to please
a girl than uh i know she's a man right
so it's harder
yeah it is and most of men they don't do
the work
they just what's that well the work is
is being a hoe basically that's how they
get and that is why and then women don't
then women feminists say oh they can't
be hoes either the guys
but then that's why but that's why paul
that's why the women that get that good
sex
keep calling that guy for that good sex
right and so we we've spoke we they they
do they
nobody generally run away
she wishes it i call her
but
remember when you said the majority the
men who give good sex let's just say men
that give good sex
they have
the women that they've given good sex to
right all of those women want that guy
to give them good sex again so the guys
that are giving good sex to women
are are heavily sought after by these
women
right
and so and so
the other
he's he he understands okay cool like i
have sex blah blah he may be a hole in
the streets or whatever but he knows
that those women will con consistently
be coming back for him
that he knows that there's because he's
given that he's given them that release
that jess was talking about right and
those women want that release and so
when they're comparing other guys
they're like those guys are just a bit
let me call this guy and he's like oh
okay you're calling now all right cool
so i had a call from susan on the monday
and then i don't know francesco on a
tuesday and he's just like okay cool
here's my options and that's why they
say men are dogs that's why a lot of the
things this whole men are dogs thing is
because those men are having sex with
these women well and it's interesting if
you ask 80 of women what they want in a
guy they list 20 of men
right so the reason we hate men and they
say things like men are trapped like if
a girl says men are trash it basically
says she's for the streets because it's
the men you're picking and you're
picking the guys that are sleeping with
everybody
yeah women aren't going for average
dudes no
like this is a degree
all right i love medium ugly men i think
they're great
okay i love average men i think they're
better looking than good looking ones
you know but usually when girls say that
the guys that they they think are medium
ugly or still above average no no
she's like yeah he's like no i had sex
with a hunchback
with a troll
with a gremlin underneath the bridge
definitely i've never had sex in public
so definitely not under a bridge
it's all right you're young you've got
time
um
[ __ ] no what no
anyway let's move on